en 1937 le 1er septembre ma vie a
basculé compromis j'ai eu un terrible
accident avec une voiture conduite par
le chauffeur de prince rainier et à ce
moment là j'avais une fracture du crâne
tout le sang puis c'est par terre et
j'ai été considéré comme groupe d'une
dizaine d'années après j'ai eu l'idée de
faire mon procédé
c'est elle n'apparaît que j'ai construit
pour éviter d'être enterré vivant en
mort apparente
alors je suis fait ces savants sur la
savourer un truc qu'il soit
commercialisé même au lieu de payer des
points non pour espérer un ensemble à
l'intérieur qui se veut le même prix
qu'une couronne fait ce que je fais
c'est uniquement pour rendre service
parce que dans ce système là il y en a
beaucoup qu'on perde et intérêts j'ai
une dame que je vais digérer ce n'est
une vingtaine d'années elle est enterrée
quand ils ont déterré pour faire le
caveau familial et bien s'était réveillé
dans son cercueil elle avait 18 ans eh
bien c'était manger toute une main tous
les doigts il y avait plus de pole avec
les vêtements mais ils ont trouvé toutes
les planches de doigts à l'intérieur du
corps des causes donc et c'est terence
800 partout avec ce système la soutint
on peut voir la position d'un défunt
sous serre alors on voit s'il a le bras
droit puis s'en va sur la gauche ou si
chez l'autre et qu'on l'a mis la sirène
dessus automatiquement tout va hualan
poulmarch omar cissé l'écartement des
bras sa joie si sous son lit à
l'écartement des pieds voilà voilà
comment ça marche
si le pied droit va sous la gauche voilà
comme ça lasallois serait bien si le
pied l'eau va sens contraire tout est
vrai et si on a la tête à droite
la voilà la tête à gauche sur la
descente il a bougé il ya un ventilateur
qui à l'intérieur qui renvoie de
l'oxygène en face la bouche
j'en ris que rien du tout distancerait
ans mort apparente absolument progrès en
démonstration tout est prévu dès prévu
on sait jamais tout peut arriver où
j'avais un an la ligue auxerre qui sont
vos crois que c'est le premier cercueil
du monde entier qui doit posséder
on alloue le papier on lâche qu'il faut
pour cissé l homme tout est prévu
alors à voir on remet en place sache
vraiment où on a la place au chef est
restreint en verve au bout des choses
sensées restreint alors on recouvre tour
et on est tranquille est les quantités
de l'été jeunes et dans le public un
avis quantité j'ai une brave femme sort
du docteur dans la région dans ma vie
plusieurs fois et que ma vieille je
serais content d'avoir un chef comme le
tiens tellement vrai que mamadou un
petit peu mieux je voudrais un petit
pose de télé à l'intérieur parce qu'un
c'est les couleurs comme ça si je me
réveille je sens ne serait pas seul